[Music]
it is time to settle into that groove
into your couch and maybe invest in
those surround sound speakers that
nobody can afford because warner
brothers just announced that they are
releasing their entire 2021 slate of
movies
in theaters and on hbo max so what
exactly does this mean for all of us
we're gonna break it all down for you
right now on the ketchup so warner
brothers dropped this bomb with the
hottest of sizzle reels last week we're
talking the matrix four godzilla vs kong
dune in the heights the suicide squad
space jam a new legacy and more
all from the comfort of your own home
provided of course you are an hbo max
subscriber
the odds of which we're betting just
heavily increased and fans were
already stoked and frankly shocked that
wonder woman 1984
is coming out on hbo max on christmas
day the same time it's coming out in
theaters
now the decision to simulcast big
premieres is being framed by warner
brothers as the best solution for an
industry that's hemorrhaging money from
delayed release dates and needs to try
something new to keep fans engaged one
thing worth mentioning
while these movies are free to watch for
hbo max subscribers they
are removing any kind of free trial and
get this each will only be available for
31 days on hbo max before going to other
video on demand rental platforms so you
better start charging your friends you
shared that password with
just kidding your username is password
it was just easier
now all of this sounds like a good
compromise to audiences movie theaters
not so much amc theaters is currently
trying to stay afloat themselves and did
not
appreciate warner offering potential
ticket buyers access to their upcoming
catalog
now amc does have a history with studios
trying to cut them out of the deal
in april they threatened to ban all
universal releases from their theaters
after trolls world tour was released on
video on demand instead of waiting till
theaters were open again
but that situation led to a then
unprecedented agreement between amc and
universal to stream films after a 14-day
window
so maybe these are just some hard
bargaining tactics i mean amc is acting
more like abc am i right
you'll always be closing now warner
universal aren't the only ones to dabble
with at-home releases
disney also flirted with a similar model
earlier this year releasing the live
action mulan on its own streaming
platform disney plus the same day it
came out in theaters
and will go head-to-head with wonder
woman on christmas with pixar's soul
which unlike milan will be free for
subscribers
you gotta think this may all just be a
response to christopher nolan's tenant
which came out exclusively in theaters
earlier this fall
after many delays and suffered at the
box office leaving many nolan fans
still wondering what tenant is even
about i mean what really happens in his
movies anyway dream reading a dream
huh i'm impressed warner brothers seems
to be offering the best of both worlds
no extra charges beyond your hbo max
subscription and the chance for fans to
see the movies they love
without worrying for their safety you
know like in the good old days of 2019
and while no one is exactly thrilled at
what the wb announcement seems to
predict
another year of staying cooped up at
home at least one director remains
optimistic
when asked about the warner decision
during a recent interview ocean's 11
director steven soderbergh who recently
signed a deal to release films on hbo
max reminded us
not to panic the theatrical business is
not going away
it's all going to come back because
let's be clear there is no bonanza in
the entertainment industry that is the
equivalent of a movie that grosses a
billion dollars or more
theatrically christopher nolan also
happened to chime in on the decision
calling it quote a real bait and switch
which is
likely the same sentiment as dune and
godzilla vs khan's legendary pictures
who are allegedly threatening the sue
warner over a lack of communication
about the decision to move their movies
to the streaming service
more on that news as we get it
well let's start over to you guys now
what do you think about warner brothers
is big announcement are you planning on
getting hbo max if you haven't already
or are you holding out to see
godzilla vs king kong on the big screen
let us know all your thoughts and
feelings in the comments section and of
course if you want more movie or
streaming news
head on over to rottentomatoes.com and
if you already know which of warner's
movies are must-sees in which you plan
on skipping harder than a scratch
blu-ray
let's keep the conversation going in our
fan group on facebook
and if you don't want to miss out on any
future episodes of this show be sure to
hit that subscribe button and
notification bell and as always we can't
thank you enough for watching the
ketchup we love your support
and we hope to see you in the next video
[Music]
bye
you